[Musique]
c'était donc l'histoire de Mac dagable
femme de Joseph Gable c'est surnommé la
première dame du Troisième Reich avec ce
documentaire réalisé par Antoine vikkin
une femme endoctrinée fanatisée à
l'extrême et vitrine féminine du régime
nazi mais les Allemands s'identifier tel
un ton soit peu à cette femme et à la
propagande dont elle faisait l'objet
ont-elles massivement soutenu clair
pleinement adhéré à l'idéologie du
régime jusqu'à participer à ses pierres
tueries nous allons en débattre
maintenant en prolongeance documentaire
sur ce plateau de débat doc on va le
faire tout d'abord avec vous Fabrice
d'Almeida bienvenue à vous bonjour nous
sommes très heureux de vous accueillir
on vous a vu dans ce documentaire et
pour cause vous étiez conseillé
historique sur ce film vous êtes
historien et vice-président de
l'université Paris 2 Panthéon Assas et
puis en matière de nazisme et bien vos
recherches ont porté notamment sur
l'historiographie des bourreaux une
approche qui met l'accent sur les
motivations des criminels nazi et puis
avec nous Marie Bénédicte Vincent
bienvenue à vous vous êtes professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
de Franche-Comté spécialiste de
l'Allemagne contemporaine et de
l'histoire de la dénazification de
l'Allemagne après 1945 bien sûr vous
êtes l'auteur entre autres de ce livre
une nouvelle histoire de l'Allemagne
édité chez Perrin merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté vous aussi notre invitation
Fabrice d'Almeida au-delà d'un portrait
de Magda Gable ce entre guillemets
première femme du Troisième Reich
première dame du Troisième Reich que
nous raconte ce documentaire que nous
venons de voir à propos des femmes
allemandes sous le régime nazi bac elle
n'était pas
ignorée au contraire les femmes
allemandes sous le régime nazi sont un
peu partout elles sont présentes
certaines s'engagent on pourra y revenir
d'autres sont un peu attentiste mais
continuent de d'exercer leur profession
leur métier comme elles l'ont toujours
fait et puis il faut pas oublier que la
République j'en ai marre a promu les
femmes en politique elle les aura permis
de voter d'entrer pleinement dans la
cité et donc sous le nazisme elle reste
pleinement dans la cité donc c'est un
peu l'ambiguïté c'est que c'est un
régime dont on pourrait penser que il
est hyper viril mais malgré son hyper
virilité ben il y a des femmes qui
occupent des fonctions importantes elle
est passée de première dame du troisième
âge à première mer du Troisième Reich
comment ce du point de vue de la
propagande commence au Père ce
changement dans la vie dans le
documentaire l'image a beaucoup servi
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a une logique
idéologique du régime qui fait que les
femmes ont une fonction bien
particulière qui est celle de la maison
et de la reproduction le but du régime
nazi c'est de fabriquer le plus possible
de petits ariens qui partiront à la
conquête de l'Europe et éventuellement à
la conquête du monde donc la fonction
première d'un femme c'est ça mais les
femmes il y en a qui sont à l'époque
déjà déjà ingénieurs déjà pilote d'avion
pilote de course de voiture et donc
celle-là elle continue leur carrière et
elles vont même être mises en avant par
le régime quand on dit première dame du
Troisième Reich ça veut dire qu'elle
était parmi les rares femmes habilités
apparaître au premier rangs de ce régime
a commencé sur les écrans de cinéma
comme on l'a vu dans dans ce
documentaire mais est-elle un tant soit
peu représentatif de ce qui était
l'allemand malgré tout alors évidemment
elle fait partie d'une élite extrêmement
fortunée elle est mariée un banquier
voilà mais émisonne man la femme de
going le numéro 2 du régime elle aussi
est très souvent mise en avant parce que
dans un dans un premier temps quand
Goering se marie avec elle et bien il va
aussi la promouvoir il va y avoir aussi
des films de propagande on va la voir
comme elle est actrice aussi beaucoup
dans les films d'actualité donc il y a
un profil j'allais dire de la dirigeante
nazie qui doit être médias compatible et
la plupart d'entre elles d'ailleurs à un
moment ou un autre se retrouve se
retrouve filmé peut-être avec une limite
qui est la femme de Himmler de
heinrichimla le patron de la SS qui elle
est un peu moins mise en avant un peu
moins filmé un peu plus timide un peu
plus pour le coup femme d'intérieur puis
il y en a une qui sera jamais mise en
avant et jamais filmé du vivant d'Hitler
c'est vaband exactement ce film elle
aurait pu apparaître parce que lorsqu'il
est question d'une pseudo relation entre
Hitler et Matt dagable en tout cas d'un
amour qui aurait pu
évoluer entre ces deux personnes il est
jamais question des Varane dans ce
documentaire il en a d'ailleurs jamais
été question du vivant on mentionne
justement son absence qui fait que elle
est elle est cachée et que donc il y a
une place vacante de première dame mais
le problème c'est que j'allais dire
factuellement elle ne devient la
première dame qu'après son mariage inné
en avril 45 avec Hitler jusque là elle
est la maîtresse la compagne et mal
malgré tout les nazis sont un peu
j'allais dire victimes de leur bonne
éducation c'est à dire que ils veulent
que chaque chose soit à sa place ils ont
beau avoir des grandes théories pour
dire oui le l'homme a rien peut avoir
plusieurs femmes et puis il va y avoir
la dominat ils peuvent même le mettre le
maître en pratique comme Martin borne le
le secrétaire de Hitler par patron du
parti mais dans les faits malgré tout il
y a une culture de l'époque où mettre en
avant une femme qui ne serait pas avec
laquelle on n'est pas marié n'est pas si
commode alors Fabrice delmeda vous avez
abordé le sujet faut peut-être commencer
par le commencement l'élection d'Hitler
faut jamais oublier qu'Hitler est arrivé
au pouvoir par les urnes première
législative c'était en 1930 et vous
l'avez dit le vote des femmes est
accordé sous la République de weimark en
1918 et le premier vote des femmes a
lieu en 1919 législative de 1930 le vote
des femmes allemandes représentent 40%
du vote en faveur du parti nazis ça
représente 3 millions de voix et puis
alors évidemment élection
deux ans plus tard en 1932 et là ce sont
6 millions 8 à peu près de femmes qui
apportent leur voix aux parties nazis
autrement dit autant que les hommes donc
au vu de ces chiffres les femmes ont
autant porté que les hommes Hitler au
pouvoir alors oui si on regarde les
femmes globalement je dirais que ce qui
est intéressant dans le parti nazi pour
expliquer ces scores formidables du
point de vue quantitatif c'est que ça a
un parti qui attrape tout toutes les
couches sociales toutes les classes
sociales et donc les femmes c'est pas en
tant que femme qu'elles votent c'est en
tant que ouvrière en tant que employé en
tant que femme éventuellement
d'agriculteurs d'agriculteurs etc donc
ce score massif de femmes c'est pas les
femmes en tant que femme c'est parce
qu'elles appartiennent à un milieu
social hors de partie nazie sa grande
spécificité c'est d'attraper toutes les
couches sociales il veut être un parti
du peuple c'est pas un parti comme le
SPD le KPT KPD qui est lié à un milieu
professionnel un milieu le milieu
ouvrier en l'occurrence et donc ça
explique même si c'est score massif
c'est parce que le parti touche dans
toutes les catégories sociales et pas
seulement comme on l'a dit longtemps les
chômeurs ou
les indépendants que on a aussi ses
scores massif de femmes voilà alors elle
vote à l'évidence elle vote pas pour la
cause des femmes parce que dans le
programme nazi et dès les années 20
c'est un programme phalocrate et
misogyne on peut le déterminer comme ça
pour caricaturer mais enfin l'idée c'est
tout de même de ramener les femmes au
foyer d'en faire des procréatrices
d'enfants aériens notamment elle vote
pas dans leur intérêt elle vote pourquoi
Adolf Hitler à ce moment-là l'idéologie
dans mind camphf il y a pas dans
minecance de chapitres qui serait dédié
aux femmes ça n'existe pas dans le thème
féminin je dirais il est dispatché dans
différents chapitres donc elle t'aime de
l'éducation il y a le thème
effectivement de la préparation à la
guerre il y a il y a tous ces thèmes là
et donc les femmes quand elles votent
pour Hitler elle je dirais elle vote
comme les hommes c'est à dire elle voit
en Hitler celui qui va sauver
l'Allemagne redresser l'Allemagne de la
crise en 193932 on est en pleine crise
économique donc la motivation du vote
c'est lutter contre la crise avant tout
c'est la condition féminine et oui et il
y a aussi un vote de rejet de la
République de weimark qui apparaît
résolu les problèmes et c'est un pays
complètement en crise il y a 37 je crois
pour cent de chômeurs en 1932 vous vous
rendez compte enfin dans la population
active plus d'un actif sur 3 est au
chômage donc c'est un vote qui
s'explique aussi par les les conditions
dans lesquelles vivent les gens tout
simplement dans la grande crise des
années 30 et payer un aspect quand même
moi me semble important c'est que le
nazisme et pense la société organique
c'est à dire que dans la société nazi
chacun a sa place et donc d'une certaine
manière il réserve une place aux femmes
cette place nous on a tendance à la
regarder comme phallocrate limitée etc
mais elle le voit pas comme ça elle ce
qu'elle voit c'est qu'on leur réserve
une place en dignité on leur dit vous
avez un espace dans lequel vous
commandez vous avez des métiers auxquels
vous pouvez accéder et vous êtes
l'équivalent des hommes mais autrement
parce que vous n'êtes vous n'êtes vous
êtes des femmes donc cette dimension
c'est dur pour nous de l'imaginer ça
mais et encore peut-être en comparant
avec d'autres sociétés par exemple on
comprend pas pourquoi par exemple en
Afghanistan il y a des femmes qui sont
protalibre c'est pareil bon elle est
très phallocrate très virile très
machiste voilà et pourtant il y a des
femmes qui soutiennent ce mouvement et
elles le font parce que dans cette
philosophie là il y a une place qui est
réservée à la femme et donc elle se
sentent une forme de dignité dans leur
position même si nous on la regarde
comme subalterne elle elle la regarde
pas comme ça elle la regarde comme
complémentaire et dans l'idéologie nazie
il y a cette dimension là il y a pas une
tribu arienne dans laquelle on ne
dessinerait que des hommes et où il y
aurait pas de femmes il y a des femmes
il y a des femmes qui peuvent être comme
les Valkyries exemple très souvent pris
chez les nazis des combattantes donc
elle se vivent comme ça elle se vivent
dans une société en guerre dans une
société menacé comme des combattantes
comme des guerrières qui préparent le
combat et qui arment les enfants pour
les emmener vers l'avenir radieux de la
conquête et du pillage de l'Europe avec
quand même cette restriction sur le fond
bien sûr il y a l'idéologie mais il y a
peu de le parti nazis c'est un parti
d'homme quand même il y a peu de femmes
alors Magda bubble c'est un cas
intéressantes
et bien sûr il y a les organisations de
masse qui gravitent les BDM les
l'équivalent des jeunesse italienne pour
les filles et les jeunes filles il y a
les organisations féminines les femmes
de tous les postes du voilà direction il
y a Magda Gomez un caractère parce que
c'est une militante qui adhère quand
même précocement au parti nazis parce
que une chose est de votée pour les
nazis et une autre et d'adhérer et de
cotiser et elle elle est dans ce cas là
et on voit d'ailleurs très bien dans le
documentaire quand elle va demander sa
carte au Parti et d'ailleurs elle
suicide incompréhension de son de son
entourage ça va pas de soi
à cette époque là d'adhérer en tant que
femme au parti nazi mais ensuite
évidemment les femmes vont être
intégrées je suis tout à fait bien
évidemment d'accord intégré en 1939 12
millions de femmes appartiennent d'une
manière ou d'une autre d'une manière ou
d'une autre ça paraît nazie et avec une
influence parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas du tout c'est pas du tout une
société démocratique donc il faut quand
on regarde ça il faut se déshabiller de
nos habitudes de nos conceptions et il
faut il faut les voir comme des gens
très différents ils sont très différents
de nous dans leur conception et donc eux
ils ont une logique qui est la logique
de proximité de réseau de fidélité de
fidélité personnelle donc une femme qui
n'a l'air de rien qui dirige une
organisation féminine à Hambourg par
exemple on peut se dire que c'est rien
qu'elle est juste dans l'organisation
féminine mais ça veut dire qu'elle a des
rencontres avec les responsables nazis
donc ça veut dire qu'elle a de
l'influence personnelle sur le
responsable politique nazi en
l'occurrence le maire dans son crocman
et donc lui il a un lien direct avec
Hitler donc ça veut dire que cette
petite bonne elle peut obtenir des
logements elle peut distribuer des
magasins elle peut distribuer des
fonctions donc elle est ultra puissante
et c'est ça qui font comprendre quand on
parle de Magnac on n'a pas beaucoup
insisté sur cet aspect dans le film mais
elle est responsable de la mode ça veut
dire que elle oriente les commandes
qu'elle défend certains couturiers ou
contraires elle va protéger un de ses
couturiers Juifs parce que elle
l'apprécie parce qu'elle le trouve bon
mais d'autres elle va les elle va les
laisser partir et donc il y a cette
capacité là aussi d'actions politiques
que que nous on trouve scandaleuse
puisque c'est du clientélisme le plus
pourri mais qui dans leur fonction leur
paraît parfaitement normal et légitime
oui je dirais que il y a un des millions
de femmes qui sont intégrés d'une
manière ou d'une autre dans les
organisations nazis qu'on a déjà évoqué
et notamment la ns fraudchaft là c'est
cette organisation la branche féminine
on pourrait dire l'organisation de masse
pour les femmes qui dépend du parti
d'une certaine manière mais vous voyez
dans ces millions de femmes je pense que
la vraie question c'est le degré
d'intégration il y a des membres il y a
des membres aussi parce que adhérer à
une organisation pour certaines les
femmes c'est une manière de ne pas
adhérer aux parties c'est une sorte de
Pise allée et puis il y a des femmes qui
sont très intégrées et qui adhèrent à
l'idéologie mais avec Dagobert on est
dans ce cas là on est dans le cas de la
femme fanatique mais les millions de
d'adhérence sont pas forcément des
mcdagubbles je pense que là il faut
distinguer selon le degré l'adhésion est
à distinguer l'adhésion profonde
idéologique était distinguée de
l'intégration comme membres d'une
organisation ça c'est je pense qu'on
peut distinguer justement les femmes qui
adhèrent à cette fameuse Ligue des
femmes nationales socialistes par
exemple il y a là-dedans des enseignants
des infirmières qui vont donc influer
disséminés l'idéologie nazie auprès des
enfants auprès des malades et appliquer
notamment tout ce qui était prévu du
côté de l'euthanasie du côté du régime
nazi on peut différencier ces femmes qui
sont elles ces femmes qui adhèrent en
priorité au parti nazie et dans les
organisations féminines du parti nazis
en fait il y a pas un profil je crois
que la recherche a bien montré qu'il y a
plusieurs motivations pour pour intégrer
il y a des il y a des femmes qui
adhèrent par par idéologie par fanatisme
je pense que MCDA bubble c'est il y a de
ça le documentaire le montre c'est ce
que démonte ce documentaire il y a des
femmes qui adhèrent par carriérisme qui
veulent tout simplement un travail ou
garder leur travail ou alors une
promotion professionnelle et dans ces
années là une promotion professionnelle
il faut bien faire son travail avoir des
compétences mais il faut avoir aussi un
feu vert un laissez-passer idéologique
donc c'est aussi un gage de conformisme
politique avec le régiment il y a des
femmes qui adhèrent aussi parce que
elles ont été entraînées tout simplement
par une amie etc donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien les
différentes motivations et encore une
fois elles sont elles sont plus réelles
en ce moment il y a une pièce qui est
jouée au Théâtre de Poche à Montparnasse
qui s'appelle une vie allemande et ça
parle d'une c'est les souvenirs d'une
d'une ancienne dactylo du Ministère de
la Propagande qui a donc travaillé dans
le Ministère de la Propagande avec
gubbles et qui arrive là pas du tout par
idéologie parce que elle cherche un
emploi et quand elle a quand elle arrive
dans on est dans cette période de de
chômage on lui a dit que
vous avez des compétences pour être
sténodactylo et qu'elle pouvait monter
et donc elle va arriver à avoir un
boulot là et elle se dit elle-même alors
là c'est là qu'on peut nuancer elle se
dit apolitique elle le fait pas par
idéologie c'est pas une marque bubble ce
qui va adhérer profondément et pourtant
elle est dans un rouage de ce Ministère
de la Propagande donc ça montre bien que
il y a voilà qu'il faut différencier les
les types d'adhésion et comment évolue
c'est adhésion au régime nazi plus on
évolue vers la guerre et vers la fin de
la guerre c'est vrai qu'il y a des voilà
les hommes vont mourir au front beaucoup
de femmes on se retrouve leur situation
à ces femmes va changer au fur et à
mesure de l'histoire de de ce régime
nazi et moi l'évolution du
matériellement elle change
matériellement parce qu'en gros à partir
de 1936-38 les le pillage interne à
l'Allemagne commence à produire ses
effets sur les non juifs parce que quand
même avoir bien présent à l'esprit que
les nazis ont dans la tête une économie
de pillage donc qu'on vole aux uns pour
donner aux autres on vole aux Juifs
allemands pour donner aux ariens
allemands ensuite on va voler l'esclaves
et les Juifs d'Europe de l'Est pour
donner aux Allemands ensuite on va même
piller la France pour donner aux
Allemands faut avoir bien présent à
l'esprit que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe c'est pas une blague hein c'est
pas une blague c'est vraiment comme ça
que ça se passe donc tant que le pillage
a rapporte en 1933-1938 bravo tout se
passe bien on est heureux 1940 on éclate
les Français quel bonheur vivent Adolf
Hitler des lettres d'amour des femmes
qui font des tentatives de suicide parce
qu'elles n'arrivent pas de rencontrer on
parle d'archives on a ces documents là
bon et donc ensuite il y a un moment où
ça se retourne fin 1942 début 1943 la
fin la bataille de Stalingrad le
retournement on commence à recevoir les
petits les petits faire-parts de décès
mais par dizaines puis par centaines et
donc les morts arrivent la mort vient et
là tout d'un coup on voit d'ailleurs
c'est la fin de cardov une femme qui a
écrit tenue son journal elle raconte ça
comment à partir de janvier 43 touchant
l'atmosphère change ça y est il commence
à avoir peur les femmes commencent à
avoir peur et commence à à vouloir
quitter ce régime mais pas totalement
puisqu'il y aura jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre des femmes qui continueront on a
des témoignages à dire mais Hitler va
trouver la super arme qui va nous
permettre de battre les alliés et de
gagner la guerre donc il y en a qui on
gagne qui ont gardé jusqu'au bout cet
espoir sur cette bascule de 403
c'est bien documenté par par la
recherche et puis le discours de gobels
au Palais des Sports de de 43 qui
annonce la guerre totale il est en
contradiction avec tout le discours
antérieur puisqu'il dit il faut que tout
le monde s'y mette et donc il faut que
les femmes retournent au travail et en
fait elles y sont déjà le nombre de
femmes est déjà les femmes elles sont
déjà plus de 1 million je crois dans les
usines d'armement dès le début de de la
guerre mais du point de vue peut-être
veuves elles ont peut-être perdu
c'est plus vous êtes au foyer c'est on a
besoin de vous pour gagner la guerre
toutes les ressources doivent être
mobilisés notamment la main d'oeuvre
féminine donc il y a ce retournement
tout à fait de de la guerre totale de
1943 qui qui du coup est intéressant du
point de vue de la propagande parce
qu'il a fallu changer le disque en fait
et il les utilisaient partout il faut
quand même dire les femmes ils les ont
utilisé partout parce que là on parle de
celle qui était au sommet de l'État mais
faut imaginer qu'il y a des femmes
gardiennes de compte concentration oui
et parmi elles d'ailleurs c'est ce que
disait Marie Vincent est tout à fait
juste il y en a qui sont là contrainte
et il y en a qui sont là volontaires il
y en a qui ont choisi d'être auxiliaire
de la SS pour faire carrière dans les
camps parce qu'elles savent qu'on gagne
un tiers de plus que une secrétaire au
Ministère de la Propagande donc elles
savent qu'elles vont mieux gagner sa vie
donc elles vont entre guillemets à l'est
pour faire fortune c'est la conquête de
l'Est à la place de la conquête de
l'Ouest que qui est si forte chez les
Américains donc il y a des femmes
partout il y en a dans les usines il y
en a dans les usines d'armement et il y
en a bien évidemment dans les camps de
concentration qui vont pour certaines
faire des des carrières et des actes
horribles c'est à dire qu'ils vont
participer dans les camps comme my ou
dans les camps comme à Auschwitz qui
vont être des auxiliaires qui vont en
partie servir notamment à commander les
gérer les commandos de femmes
parfois avec violence avec meurtre il
faut quand même dire la vérité il y en a
une qui sera connue qu'on appelle l'ange
blonde qui va être en procès en 1945
pourquoi parce qu'elle lâchait son chien
sur les détenus et mettre le chien tout
à fait à l'est il y a ces gardiennes et
puis comme vient de le dire Fabrice
Almeida il y a toutes les professions
qui sont mobilisées les professions
classées habituellement comme féminines
à l'époque des puéricultrice des
secrétaires des institutrices des
dactylos qui vont être envoyés à l'est
alors ça a été chiffré récemment on
évalue à peu près à 500.000 ans je crois
le nombre de femmes que j'ai sous les
yeux ça sans fil femme
contribue à la colonie des territoires
conquises
et c'est donc pour certaines jeunes
femmes c'est des débuts de carrière
prometteurs c'est des promesses
évidemment qu'on de de colonisation
il y a tout le rêve aussi de la
colonisation derrière donc c'est toutes
ces professions féminines qui vont être
finalement intégrés dans cette dans
cette
dans la conquête aussi une émancipation
sociale souvent des femmes d'un milieu
sociaux défavorisés qui comme vous
l'avez dit va on s'en doute gagner un
tiers de salaire en plus que les
fonctionnaires présentent à
berliné à une émancipation d'un certain
nombre de femmes allemandes qui jusque
là étaient issus du milieu défavorisé
alors il y a l'indépendance économique
par le salaire individuel qui pour
certaines femmes célibataires et est
important puisque dans il y a un certain
nombre de d'épouses mariés qui ont été
renvoyés quand même dans dans leur foyer
au début du régime parce que justement
on considérait dans la fonction publique
on considérait notamment que si le mari
gagnait sa vie la femme pouvait être
envoyée donc pour les femmes
célibataires c'est un moyen
d'indépendance économique c'est des
professions associées à une
une campagne prestigieuse quand même
nous on voit la débâcle et on voit
l'horreur mais à l'époque on vend le
rêve la colonisation la supériorité sur
sur l'islam et puis il y a l'idée
qu'elles vont être utiles entre
guillemets dans ce projet et reconnu
pour leur propre compétences donc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui rentrent en
compte est-ce que vous évoquiez la
bascule de 43 dans l'opinion des femmes
allemandes comment elle se caractérisée
cette cette bascule chez les femmes
allemandes il y a eu des poches de
résistance de résistance passive
j'imagine peut-être il n'était pas
question de d'organiser des résistances
au vu de tous dans ce type de régime
on peut on peut en dire un peu plus sur
ce qu'on était
la situation c'est adhésion des femmes
allemandes entre 43 et 45
alors je sais pas si c'est 43 45 mais il
y a une injonction qui est de procréée
quand même dans le dans le dans le
régime nazi et la fécondité par exemple
elle augmente pas durant le régime nazi
donc il y a une résistance de vente on
va dire c'est à dire il n'y a pas plus
d'enfants sous le nazisme par femme le
taux de fécondité que qu'avant
globalement donc la famille gablese avec
ses 6 enfants c'est une famille vitrine
mais il faut pas s'imaginer que toutes
les femmes aussi sans faute rien que ça
je trouve que déjà ça montre une
distance vis-à-vis des modèles
idéologiques qui sont et a fortiori
pendant la guerre il y a des formes faut
pas l'oublier il y a quand même des
femmes qui sont opposées aux nazismes
des le grand exemple quand moi je garde
toujours en tête c'est c'est Marlène
Dietrich parce que c'est c'est le
symbole et qu'elle refuse et que avant
guerre elle est partie et qu'elle veut
pas coopérer avec ce régime là donc il y
a des femmes il y a des femmes
résistantes dans la rose blanche une des
figures essentielles est une jeune fille
même pas majeure d'ailleurs qui va
mourir des capitaux donc il y a cette la
rose blanche mouvement de résistance
donc il y a cette dimension qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est à dire que là on a
parlé beaucoup de l'adhésion mais il
faut pas oublier qu'il y a ça et puis il
faut pas oublier tout toute seule qui
vont être travailleuses déportés forcées
et qui vont se retrouver parfois pour
certaines dans des bordels dans des
camps donc voilà faut aussi avoir même
si c'est une ultra minorité parce que on
ne dira jamais assez il y a finalement
assez peu d'oppositions en fait
politique au nazisme la vraie opposition
politique analyste c'est quoi c'est
c'est 20000 personnes qui s'enfuient 200
000 qui sont mises en camp pour un pays
qui va compter à peu près entre 60 et 80
millions d'habitants donc voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est on est on est dans
des échelles qui sont qui sont très
faibles donc après 43 en réalité là où
on sent le désaccord c'est qu'en fait
les gens ne vont plus dans les soirées
où ils ne sont pas obligés d'aller et là
on voit les cercles qui se ferment c'est
à dire qu'en fait une femme commerciale
à 24 justement elle elle ne va plus du
tout voir ses gens là et il faut pas
penser il faut pas penser que c'est
uniquement j'allais dire une démarche
politique c'est aussi un effondrement
intérieur la nourriture va petit à petit
commencer à devenir rare enfin j'allais
dire après avoir pillé toute l'Europe à
leur tour ils vont connaître un peu la
fin et puis ils vont se dire on veut
plus être avec eux et ils commencent à
faire le calcul inverse de si continuer
de rester et de fréquenter ces gens là
ce qu'il risque d'avoir après la défaite
parce que il intériorise à partir de en
gros de la fin de l'année 44 tout le
monde est à peu près sûr de ce qui va se
passer on va s'interroger je suis
bientôt la fin de cette émission nous
reste que quelques 5 minutes sur ce qui
a été le travail des historiens
concernant notre sujet du jour
c'est-à-dire l'adhésion le degré
d'adhésion des fois mallements de au
régime nazi et c'est vrai que les femmes
allemandes ont longtemps été présentées
comme des victimes dans ce régime
victime d'un régime phalocrate et
souvent présenté comme profondément
misogyne et je vais citer Johann
chaputaud qui qui dit élaboré par les
hommes une historiographie entretient
l'idée que la guerre a été une affaire
d'homme dit-il et il s'agissait de
sortir les femmes des radars dans ces
fameuses recherches historiques pour ne
pas écorner l'image de la femme
naturellement et innocente ce qui
revenait à dire que toute l'Allemagne
était pourrie c'est pour ça qu'on a on a
une approche
des historiens jusqu'à il y a très peu
de temps d'ailleurs
je pense que le premier en question
aujourd'hui par certaines historiennes
justement de ce qui ont été les femmes
ce régime les femmes allemandes ok il y
a eu longtemps effectivement l'idée que
les femmes étaient si non victimes du
moins innocente du nazisme tout le monde
n'est pas victime quand même si
innocente que cela à vous écouter
je dirais que c'est c'est un produit de
la frégate c'est un produit de la près
45 sur laquelle on a vécu dans
l'historiographie jusqu'à quand même je
dirais quand même les années 80 depuis
les années 1980-90 l'histoire des femmes
a quand même nuancé fortement déjà on
essaie de déconstruire les femmes ça
veut rien dire en fait il y a plein de
groupes de milieu et donc professionnel
sociaux etc donc on essaie de d'éviter
de généraliser et puis justement les
recherches récentes vont pointer ces cas
de femmes
on pourrait dire bourreau qui sont des
cas extrêmes ou des femmes fanatiques
comme Magda bubbles qui sont des
contrepoints qui font contrepoints ou
par rapport à cette à cette vision qui
était agréable en fait de l'après son
guerre mondiale on disait bon il y a des
coupables mais on a circonscrit le
cercle de manière claire il y a eu les
procès il y a une Nuremberg donc on voit
bien qui étaient les coupables
maintenant ils sont soit morts soit ils
ont été sanctionnés bon déjà on pourrait
nuancer mais et puis comme ça tout le
monde et dédouané ça arrangé tout le
monde aussi et comme la société en tout
cas West allemande c'est construite
quand même sur
cette ce discours et cette
représentation du nazisme ça a été
ensuite il a fallu ensuite dans
l'historiographie je dirais la dépasser
pour aboutir aujourd'hui à un regard
heureusement que nuancé je vais vous
donner la parole dans un instant vous
êtes une spécialiste de la
dénazification je l'ai dit on vous
présentant
la dénazification a-t-elle eu lieu du
côté des femmes dont on a parlé dans ce
débat après 1944 alors il des femmes qui
ont été tout à fait des naziés on a
alors peut-être moins que les hommes
parce que les la des nazification a
touché inégalement les secteurs
professionnels et les secteurs
professionnels qui ont été les plus
concernés notamment l'administration
c'est des secteurs à encore très
masculins en 1945 mais par exemple une
énigme Stein qui est pourtant pas membre
du parti nazi elle a été des naziée par
les Français dans leur zone d'occupation
et parce que c'était aussi pour pour au
niveau international une quand même une
une
cinéaste qui avait collaboré qui s'était
compromise gravement dans le régime donc
oui on sait que des femmes ont été des
nazifiées bien sûr
les procès de camps de concentration
pourquoi cette évolution de la du
travail des historiens concernant ce
sujet la place des femmes dans le régime
nazi peut-être parce que
d'abord il y a eu la prise en compte
effectivement de la place des femmes
dans l'histoire qui est quand même un
mouvement historiographique qui a
commencé dans les années 80 je pense à
Michel Perrault si jamais elle nous
écoute on lui fait un petit salut qui a
été une de celle qui a été pionnière
là-dedans et qui a fait cette histoire
des femmes et puis il y a par ailleurs
le fait que on a eu quand même une
situation des femmes allemandes qui a
été très marquée par l'après-guerre dans
le récit collectif des Allemands
l'après-guerre c'est l'âge du viol c'est
à dire qu'à peu près un demi million
d'allemandes ont été violés par les
armées d'occupation et notamment par les
Soviétiques et enfin bon notamment
faut pas penser que
qu'il y a que qui ont eu des
comportements douteux voilà
on a eu quelques échos aussi de soldats
américains donc voilà bon donc il y a eu
quand même ce phénomène massif qui a été
très longtemps ref et qui est ressorti
un années 80 et qui est fait année 90 et
qui fait que tout d'un coup on s'est
posé la question de la situation réelle
des femmes concrètes et là tout d'un
coup ben il y a des documents qui ont
été publiés des livres de secrétaire
d'Adolf Hitler qui disait je suis
apolitique notamment une des secrétaires
il y en a d'autres que voilà et toutes
ces petites sources qu'on avait pas
tellement regardé parce que on les
regardait comme des produits de la
nostalgie de quelque chose de des gens
qu'il fallait pas voir ben tout d'un
coup on s'est dit ben qu'est-ce que ça
nous donne si on essaye de regarder
concrètement ce que faisait les uns et
les autres sachant que nous ne sommes
pas un juge parce que les juges de
l'après-guerre ils devaient juger
effectivement s'il y avait eu
collaboration à un meurtre un crime nous
on est historiens donc on peut regarder
s'il y a une inconscensus une
participation ou pas je dirais que
l'histori aujourd'hui elle déplace
peut-être un petit peu le regard
actuellement moins vers les figures de
proue que on regarde plus la question du
consentement dit c'est le nazisme c'est
qui a qui a obtenu le consentement
l'adhésion et donc de ce fait on est
obligé de regarder les femmes parce que
elle compose la société comme les hommes
et donc ça a déplacé un peu le les
problématiques parce que les nazis les
hauts dirigeants c'est quand même
massivement des enfin ils sont quand
même tous des hommes de déplacer le
regard en se demandant mais finalement
pourquoi la société adhère d'où vient le
consentement puisque il y a de la
contrainte et du consentement d'ailleurs
c'est très bien rappelé par Royan
chaputaud dans le dans le dans le
documentaire et bah du coup ça ça repose
la question de l'adhésion des femmes
voilà donc c'est aussi un des points sur
lesquels aujourd'hui sans doute la
recherche est amenée à réfléchir les
questions sur le nazisme évoluent et du
coup ben chaque à chaque étape on va
regarder des des enjeux ici la question
des femmes me paraît assez centrale dans
les dans les dans les questions
aujourd'hui posées à mesure que la
guerre s'éloigne aussi on peut porter un
regard plus ample quand on était près de
l'événement on regardait les montagnes
de souffrance de dest de crime donc
l'Allemagne année zéro
c'était souvent
caritatives et ça aveuglé tout ça
prenait la totalité de la vision là on
est et nos ancêtres en 1945 sont obsédés
par la question du déclenchement de la
guerre c'était ça qui les obsédait donc
il voulait juger ce qui avait déclenché
la guerre nous on nous éloignant on veut
juger ceux qui ont fait le régime ces
différents c'est pas la même perspective
ce sera le mot de la fin Fabrice dalmeda
un grand merci hein vraiment à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
consacré aux femmes allemandes et le
nazisme vous pouvez bien entendre réagir
à cette émission ça sera sur hashtag des
Badoc sur Twitter des voix tous et à
toutes pour un prochain débat doc ça
sera bien sûr avec son documentaire et
son débat à bientôt
[Musique]